magnus is ready hi minus congratulations
thank you take us through the emotions
right now
i mean what a huge win two must-win
situations in the end here
yeah um it's pretty sick like i came
back
five times when i sort of needed to win
yeah
and i also lost twice when i was up
but it was just absolutely insane
uh and
you know i i'm just so happy
to have pulled through how how
good is it also to finally win the final
against wesley so third time lucky
finally
no it's uh it's uh it's a massive
massive massive relief i do feel
uh at the end that we were both pretty
broken uh and
yeah sometimes it goes your way
um but uh yeah it
was a great fight yeah and when you
managed to take
the get the tie break to armageddon i
mean what were your
what were you thinking were you feeling
confident of your chances
i wouldn't say i was confident per se
but i i did
feel i did feel as though there were
decent chances yeah
um so i wasn't even that unhappy that he
chose
chose black i i thought if
if we neither of us are playing our best
and
having the extra minute it's nice it's
in the end that turned out to be pretty
uh important
magnus what were you doing between the
games especially when it came down to
the blitz and the armageddon
well before the second game i was mainly
kicking and screaming in disgust
and then yeah before the before the
armageddon i was
i don't know just trying to
to uh to become was wasn't easy and
i certainly wasn't calm when we played
and
we've seen it uh on your reactions a lot
of emotions the shock from wesley taking
that
quick draw in the final game and
obviously
how angry you were after the first blitz
loss how happy you were after the second
blitz win
and then the armageddon i do you feel
exhausted now basically
no i feel fine now
[Music]
ready to go again but i i will uh yeah i
certainly will feel
feel exhausted after a while so it's uh
yeah this was this was never ever like
my tournament like nothing
nothing came easy at all uh
so i mean that's why it's really really
really satisfying to to come out on on
top and
um yeah i think
both wesley and i can play better uh but
yeah it's not really important to me
right now
and of course two wins two tournament
wins in a row now in the meltwater
champions chess tour
this is a major so finally you're secure
the spot in the tour
final what does that mean to you as well
no
i wasn't that concerned with that i
thought
since i i mean i was leading the tour
before this so
but obviously like winning winning this
one with all
all the all the best guys is a massive
deal
and uh i i'll try to um
to take the one seed into into the final
which i i should have a very good chance
of doing
well yeah you mentioned it such a strong
tournament one of the strongest in
history all the top 10 players from the
get-go so
you i mean from the start when you lost
that first final to wesley in the
skilling open you were talking a little
bit about
motivation and just not too motivated
how are you feeling about that
right now uh i mean still
sort of constant goes but certainly now
there was
there was no no problem with that um and
i mean you could see
to with the naked eye that it it means
something to me so
absolutely and of course i know you
never play for the money magnus but
you know there is a hundred thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin also in the
price fund here
have you been following the bitcoin at
all are you at all interested in
cryptocurrencies
uh yeah i'm
i would say i'm moderately moderately
interested i have
i have some bitcoin uh already but
uh no i wasn't like following the price
to see how much
my price would be um
but it's yeah if it's if it's gone up
then it's it's a nice bonus
magnus what will you do now to recover
and to celebrate and maybe to prepare
for the next tournament in june
oh no idea oh i
i i yeah i haven't planned further than
than this um i'm gonna um yeah
probably try and relax for uh for a
couple of
a couple of days like i don't
i i mean i i don't now there's
adrenaline but
i don't feel feel that great so i'll
just need to
to um you know recharge a bit
and uh finally we saw you we saw some
fantastic videos where you were being
challenged
uh which one was your favorite challenge
you know was it the memory test
was it speed
concentration concentration yeah the
geography yeah i don't i don't even
remember
half of it not the memory challenge
not the memory very impressive all right
magnus
uh we are so happy for you huge
congratulations on finally winning a
final against
wesley thank you thanks for joining us